first on CBS this morning we are hearing
from women interviewed for a new
documentary who claimed that music mogul
Russell Simmons violently assaulted them
now he has denied these allegations
vigorously last week Oprah who was an
executive producer for the film withdrew
her support because of a difference in
creative vision with the filmmakers she
also sent the film's producers a letter
saying that she believes that women
interviewed for this documentary
Michelle Miller spoke with the three of
them and joins us at the table Michelle
what they tell you it told us a lot good
morning the women we spoke with went
into detail about what they alleged were
serious assaults they are also speaking
out after being silent for decades we'd
also like to warn our viewers some of
what you were about to hear is graphic I
did not want to come forward it was the
last thing I want to do everyone say
don't do it it's gonna ruin your life I
felt but no matter what I said nobody
was gonna hear us I was helping him
cover it up for 22 years and I thought
well let me see what it feels like to
just let it go when we try drew Dixon
Szalai Abrams and Alexia Norton Jones
say they're all survivors of sex crimes
committed by media mogul Russell Simmons
the three of you are describing this
just as sexual assault or just as being
mistreated by Russell Simmons or
sexually arrest by Russell no this is
petrol rape this is violently tackled
and raped it's all saying no and
fighting and crying Dru Dixon says she
was working with Simmons when he
allegedly attacked her in 1995 I've
literally worked for him he was ordering
me a car and he told me to come upstairs
and pick up a demo I thought I would be
in his apartment for five total minutes
that's it and he showed up naked wearing
a condom and tackled me to his bed while
I screamed and fought and said no and
cried that's right salah abram says she
occasionally dated russell sin
I mean back in the day we would just say
you hooked up I mean you hung out
regardless she says that part of their
relationship was over before Simmons
allegedly raped her in 1994 he'll say
yes we had a sexual relationship but he
cannot address the fact that I was too
drunk to consent and that the next day I
called him up screaming and I attempted
suicide he knew and I told him why that
he had ruined my life and that I had
nothing Russell Simmons said all of his
relationships have been consensual and
in a statement to CBS this morning said
I have issued countless detailed denials
of the false accusations against me
these denials have been validated by my
passing nine prosecution gray
lie-detector tests he also referenced
changing social norms saying I have
admitted to being a massively
unconscious Playboy which today is
appropriately titled womanizer the
social change from today's activism is
more important to the world my daughters
will inherit than any dirt from false
accusations from nearly 40 years ago I'm
not trying to take anybody down you know
I would have been taken down by this if
I had said this when I was 24 years old
their decision to speak out publicly
came after a groundswell of sexual
assault allegations against prominent
men like Harvey Weinstein it felt like
this portal opened suddenly where women
were being believed and I wondered if
that would apply to black women each of
these women filed a police report
decades after the alleged crimes were
committed and beyond the statute of
limitations to prosecute Russell Simmons
faces no charges still coming forward is
complicated for his accusers black
people have very few heroes to spare not
many of us get to the level of success
of a Russell Simmons which is why I was
so proud of him
as co-founder of Def Jam
wordings Russell Simmons is considered a
pillar of hip-hop culture which he
helped to define from its earliest days
through music and fashion flavor I had
known Russell for many years you know I
met him in my early 20s alexia Norton
Jones knew Russell Simmons before he was
famous and says he raped her on their
first and only date in 1991 this was a
very swift attack and what was going
through my mind more than anything was
why was just a why because I liked
Russell and I you know I would have just
a a kissed um I would have made out with
him I would have either he didn't have
to attack me what did he do he raped me
right up against the wall
she's my language a number of women have
alleged similar experiences with Russell
Simmons for a documentary set to
premiere at the Sundance Film Festival
at the end of the month
I hope black women and girls become more
visible as a result of this documentary
when Oprah Winfrey was announced as an
executive producer of the documentary in
December
Simmons launched a private and public
campaign to question her involvement
saying on Instagram I have never been
violent or forced myself on anyone he is
a media mogul so the back you have
millions of followers I have like a
thousand and he is using all of that
muscle to try to drown out our voices
citing creative differences Oprah
Winfrey stepped away from the
documentary last week and then a
statement said there is more work to be
done in the film to illuminate the full
scope of what the victims endured she
also bolstered her backing of the
accusers by adding I wanted to be known
that I unequivocally believe and support
the
it's a small black world and because
everything is one degree of Brussels
Simmons and nobody wants to get in the
middle nobody stands up it's almost as
if you are saying maybe I shouldn't have
stepped forward is it worth it to you to
had your say I feel that it's worth it
because it's really it was like carrying
like a malignant cancer I'm just
relieved to be done enabling him
essentially by not telling people what
he did the filmmakers of a documentary
say it was always destined for the
Sundance Film Festival with or without
Oprah Winfrey as its executive producer
and they yet to be titled film is
scheduled to premiere at Sundance on
January 25th that was very difficult to
hear Michelle I have to say and I'm glad
you pointed out that that documentary
was going to Sundance with or without
Oprah's Oprah's Oprah's name on it
because I know that this was a very
stressful and very difficult decision
for her to take her name off because she
knows that her taking her name off
because as you point out Russell has
done a very public and very private
campaign to convince her she knows that
the message that sends that maybe she
was muscled muzzled nothing can be
furthered from the case she was very
upset with she thought that the
documentary need to breathe a little
more she thought it was important that
it be put in context for the times
because you know these allegations for
many years ago and now we're here in
2020 put it in context of the times as
what of what was going on there and
really it's centered the documentary
centered around Dru Dixon that one
individual there were a few other people
involved she wanted more women exactly
in the documentary thank you very much a
very powerful story
you